hi carlos hey good to see you um
so very excited for not just a show but
for you in general
i mean oh you got me yeah there you are
yeah
um before joining the mcu were you one
of those fans that would like
discuss what's coming next and talk
about all the easter eggs and all that
like how excited would you get about
what's coming next
i was excited i wasn't the one who could
break down all the easter eggs and
could anticipate what was coming next i
was the person who was in the theater
oh yes like that was me like i'm here
for the fighting i'm here for the
the storytelling like that's me i the
the easter eggs and how it connected and
went back
i wasn't so great at i'm still not but
the movie in and of itself oh i'm here
for that i'm here for that
well what's interesting about you know
one division is that that whole thing
about the fighting and the action
i mean we don't get that right off the
bat were you surprised about the
direction that this show was
was going to take when they first told
you about it
you you don't get it right off the bat
but what i love
about wanda vision is that it is
infusing
um you know it is an homage to american
television across the decades
and it does infuse that big epic
marvel movie production in there you
just have to
hang tight until you get there and you
figure out
what's going on um all the little things
that are being revealed
um but what when i heard what they were
doing
i looked at jack our head writer i was
like you are
oh you are brilliant um
and i am so excited to be a part of this
because
she just took such great care
and paid attention to detail and making
sure that you know the language was good
for uh
appropriate for each decade and um
in the tone and the feel and like jokes
are different in the 50s than they are
in the 2000s so
i i'm really excited and i was really
excited when i read it
now we know that you are monica rambo
because we know that you know captain
marvel 2
is happening your captain marvel was
actually my first captain marvel
in the comics like that was the captain
marvel that i knew when i first started
reading comics so i'm
super excited to see where that goes do
you
how excited are you for the fans to
watch this show and
kind of have to go on the journey with
you because
oftentimes we as comic fans think we
know you know what's coming up next
right
um i'm i'm really excited because the
fans have
definitely been um tweeting me and
engaging me on instagram
and they're letting me know that they're
waiting and
i i'm i'm really excited for what you
know the future
holds for monica in the mcu but
she her history is just so rich in the
comic books that they could pull from
anywhere
and so it will be a surprise and
exciting to all of us
how does being in um you know in our
pandemic times
change the idea of get getting into like
mcu shape
that is a great question i think
there's uh getting into mcu shape
physically and mentally
um and i i definitely thought it would
be
different i am very grateful that comic
con 2019
happened in person because the way that
felt and feeling the energy of the fans
i would have been really sad if that had
to be announced during
you know quarantine um because that
feeling can't be replaced so there are a
lot of different elements
of like trying to physically work out
and get in shape
when i thought you know i would be in
the gym drinking my water and like yeah
your turn you're up next but i'm not i'm
in the garage
cold with hand weights trying to figure
it out or running
outside trying to jog in 35 degree
weather to get it together because i
don't have a treadmill
um so it's very different than i
imagined
but you know it's it's a challenge that
i will talk about hopefully when we're
all safer on the other side of this
pandemic
and it is what it is and just having to
readjust my mind to
not diminish or dismiss where i am but
to embrace it
that's all we can do well we got to get
you a treadmill i'm excited for
everything coming up for you
uh thank you so much for your time thank
you
you